[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a hong kong chinese
culinary drama film called cook up a
storm spoilers ahead watch out and take
care
the movie centers around a famous local
restaurant named the seven in spring
avenue hong kong the talented chef of
the restaurant sky co specializes in
southern style cuisine a tv host
features the 30 year old restaurant and
its chef on a culinary program skye
shows his talent on national television
even though he is already popular as the
best chef in all of spring avenue
alongside him his friend uni is also
introduced to the people she usually
manages the financial aspect of the
restaurant skye is very definitive about
the quality of food and time they
provide to their customers which is part
of the reason why their restaurant is so
popular most of the time it is so packed
that a queue of people has to line up
outside the restaurant that day a rude
customer barges in after breaking up the
queue skye refuses to serve him even
though the customer boasts about the
power and money he possesses before
leaving the man laughs at their small
restaurant and discloses that his boss
has invited a world-class chef to open a
three-star restaurant opposite to theirs
the thought scares yuni but she
dismisses it as a bluff meanwhile in
france the crowned king and queen are
welcoming their newborn son they hold a
massive ball to celebrate the birth and
invite a world-class chef to cook for
the guests we are introduced to the said
chef paul ahn he is a michelin-starred
korean chef trained in france paul has a
special way of cooking that doesn't see
boundaries in one particular style he
loves to mix cuisines from different
countries and thus create innovative
dishes for the chef's special he
presents the queen with a dessert that
looks like a red egg but is filled with
mango puree and coconuts gross the dish
is inspired by the tradition that
symbolizes red eggs as a blessing to the
newborn the delicious dish and the
meaning behind it touched the royals
hearts and they applaud paul's brilliant
work after the successful ball he and
his assistant myo return to the
restaurant that they currently work for
the owner and their co-workers welcomed
them with cheers congratulating them on
their success the owner also announces
that they have promoted paul to the
executive chef of the whole art nouveau
franchise this step is a huge one for
him however to everyone's surprise he
declines the offer paul wants to return
to asia and pursue a bigger and higher
ambition he and mayo have been invited
by a chinese businessman who wants to
open a three-star restaurant the staff
supports their decision and wishes them
farewell back on spring avenue one of
skye's regular customers informs him
that the rumor about the new restaurant
being established is true the news is
bittersweet for skye because he wants
his small colony to develop but a new
restaurant would mean fewer customers
and more competition when skye was 10
years old his father used to hit him and
insult him for having no talent as a
cook one day he abandoned skye and chose
to pursue his culinary career over being
a father with the excuse being that skye
couldn't even make a decent bowl of
noodles imagine your dad leaving because
of noodles ever since uncle seven the
master and owner of the seven
restaurants has taken care of him he
also taught skye everything that he
needed to know about food unlike his
father currently sky hasn't met his
father in over 20 years and has no plan
to reconcile with him the following
morning paul arrives in hong kong and
goes to the market in search of a big
grouper fish the seller has only one of
the fish and decides to sell it to sky
knowing that he will cook it better paul
argues insisting that a shopkeeper
shouldn't be biased they get into a
small argument before the seller cuts
the fish in half for both of them a few
weeks later is the opening ceremony of
the three-star restaurant named stellar
that is right in front of the seven
restaurant the chairman and manager of
the lee management group arrives as the
first guests of the restaurant and are
welcomed by paul and mayo at the same
time the people from the seven
restaurants start announcing different
discount offers they're offering for the
next week when the security guards from
the stellar restaurant try to stop them
a conflict arises this attracts paul and
the guests attention making them come
out to see what the fuss is about when
the conversation gets heated maya
suggests they hold a competition to see
which cook is better skye and paul
recognize each other from the market and
accept the challenge they decide to
indulge in a fish cutting competition
paul goes first and skillfully picks all
of the ribs from a fish in no time
following that sky takes the same fish
and cuts it into even pieces in under a
minute the crowd claps for him and even
paul is impressed the chairman of the
league group has to announce the results
in an unbiased way he claims that the
true results will only be announced in
the international chef challenge
competition that both chefs have taken
part in he also announces that he is
planning to take over the entire spring
avenue colony to remove all of the
buildings and modernize it if sky wins
in the competition the chairman is
willing to withdraw his plan to preserve
the heritage of the colony however if
paul wins he will go through with the
plan with the future of the entire
colony in his hands skye feels pressured
but still he is determined to do his
best for the next few days the number of
customers at the seven restaurant
decreases uni is worried that they might
soon go out of business but sky assures
her that is not possible he gives her
the example of escargot and field snails
claiming that there will always be
people who like one more than the other
they do not have to change their food to
be better than the stellar restaurant
because there will always be customers
who like theirs better the following day
skye is met with disappointment when he
goes to the market and finds out that
the stellar restaurant has bought all
the good fish the day is frustrating for
the workers in the seven restaurant
until they find out that skye has been
selected for the culinary competition he
will soon go against paul to be selected
for the semifinals but then it is also
announced that the victor will have to
go against the two-time winner of the
competition mountain co sky is shocked
to see that his father has achieved the
success he wanted to he is now even more
determined to reach the finals and
compete against him that night seven
returns home from his trip and calls sky
to a pub excited to meet him after so
long skye runs to the location but finds
his father with uncle seven mountain
bluntly says that he still doesn't
believe in sky and doesn't regret
leaving him for his career the words are
the most hurtful thing skye has ever
heard but he hides his pain with anger
he promises to win the competition and
prove that being a good cook doesn't
require being a bad person like mountain
is on the day of the culinary duel the
contestants get 90 minutes to cook a
dish of their choice and present it skye
makes a traditional salt-baked duck
while paul makes a foie gras or bay the
entire 90 minutes are intense as both
cooks show great expertise while cooking
their respective dishes sky cuts the
ducks insides with little to no effort
and pulls them out efficiently making
the audience gasp in the end he bakes
the duck in salt and breaks the
additional layer to reveal a well-cooked
duck with vegetable stuffings the judges
try it and seem to be more impressed by
skye's duck than paul's sorbet when it
is time to vote paul receives three
nines and a whopping 10 out of 10
scoring a total of 37 points right after
skye receives two tens from the first
two judges the third judge gives him a
nine but the last judge only gives him
an eight because both chefs have tied in
points the head judge makes the
executive decision to make paul the
winner because his dish presentation was
superior to skye's bland plating
although paul's victory should have
solidified his abilities as a cook
things did not go as expected while
celebrating their victory the manager
informs paul that he wants to replace
him with mayo to compete in the finals
according to him a woman is more
appealing in the media than a man when
paul tries to defend his position as
head chef maya exposes that he has
difficulty tasting certain flavors like
saltiness for the past few months he has
been using a notebook containing all his
recipes to cook and can do nothing on
his own maya also discloses that she
never wanted to befriend paul and only
sided with him to surpass him as a chef
betrayed and hurt paul storms out of the
restaurant never to look back that night
skye bumps into a drunk paw in front of
an event stadium they forget about their
rivalry for a few minutes and share
their past and troubles paul reveals
that his father was a great chef and his
dying wish was for paul to be like him
skye also tells him about his and
mountain's relationship after the
conversation they find mutual respect
for each other they also throw bottles
of alcohol at mountain's picture on a
billboard while cursing at him in korean
paul doesn't want to give up on the
competition yet since he cannot take
part as a representative of the stellar
restaurant he decides to participate as
an individual chef after debunking the
rule book he even asks skye to join him
for the semifinals at the same time the
manager of stellar is at the seven
restaurant urging uncle seven to sign
away his restaurant to the league group
right then paul and skye appear and
announce their partnership paul also
reminds the manager that as the winner
of the competition he is eligible to
compete at the championship for the next
few weeks skye and paul work and train
together they try each other's styles of
cooking and reach a common ground of
modernization of traditional cuisine the
semi-final of the culinary competition
takes place at the studio city casino in
macau the one to win the round will have
to face the current god of cookery
mountain co the competition starts and
skye and paul use both their culinary
strengths to compete against four other
great chefs from different parts of the
world somehow the league group has also
made mayo take part in the competition
she cooks extra carefully to prove that
she is better than paul she makes an
oyster dish with frozen foam that the
judges compliment initially but on being
served they seem to find it mediocre
meanwhile paul and skye create a
deconstructed mapo tofu skye's sense of
taste helps determine the flavor of
ingredients while paul's understanding
of the culinary artistry helps with the
techniques and processes used together
they create a traditional dish with a
modern design the judges compliment the
dish in detail thoroughly impressed by
it in the end they win the competition
and reach the finale as everyone cheers
paul looks at mayo who stands with her
head low ashamed that she betrayed him
and couldn't prove herself for the final
round only one of the chefs can compete
against mountain paul thinks that
because of his lack of taste he is
ineligible to participate he knows that
skye's desire to beat mountain is a very
personal one hence he suggests sky face
mountain in the finals the following day
skye stands face to face with his father
the competition asks them to cook
anything they want in an hour the father
and son do not share words before the
competition starts mountain immediately
begins to cook but skye is distracted by
his thoughts he remembers how mountain
abandoned him and how much the people in
the neighborhood mean to him the
thoughts overwhelm sky and he can hardly
focus to get him to come back to his
senses mountain splashes water at his
son's face the action brings skye back
and he immediately starts making dough
by the end of the hour mountain makes an
aesthetic sugar display of molten lava
with a flower on top in contrast skye's
dish is a bit more simple but personal
he makes noodles like the noodles that
mountain made years ago before
abandoning his son the judges try
mountain's dish and are impressed by it
however skye never hands his dish to
them
instead he gives the bowl of noodles to
mountain mountain eats it and is moved
as he remembers what the noodles
represent at last he has no choice but
to acknowledge his son's brilliance in
culinary art the winner of the
competition is unclear but the judges
never got to taste the food in the
following scene we see a crowd has
gathered outside the seven restaurant to
celebrate the chinese new year they
enjoy a meal cooked by skye and paul
together as a family subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching